[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUDHEERA VANGURI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Sudheera Vanguri, and
I'm the product manager
for language AI
here in Cloud AI.
I would like to welcome
you here and thank you
for taking the time to
talk about the latest
developments in Translate
and Natural Language AI.
Fun fact-- we couldn't
put AutoML in there
until this morning because
of yesterday's announcements.
So that's what we're going to
be spending most of our session
on.
Why we are here today?
So a quick agenda on what I'll
be covering as part of today's
session.
The first part, I'm going
to talk about Cloud Natural
Language and Cloud
Translation, and dive
deeper and give you an overview
of AutoML Natural Language
and AutoML Translate.
Following that, we have
two customer case studies--
two customer use cases on
both AutoML Natural Language
and AutoML Translate.
We have guest speakers
from Qualtrics,
and Welocalize, one of
the largest localization
vendors in the US.
And towards the
end of the session,
I'll also provide
some useful resources.
So finally, we can talk about
AutoML Translation and AutoML
Natural Language.
We have spent months working
on these new products
and new capabilities in Cloud
Translation and Cloud Natural
Language.
Let's do a quick deep dive.
Cloud Translation was one of our
first forays into AI and APIs,
and this has been a
well-loved API since 2011,
we support hundreds
of languages,
from Afrikaans to Zulu,
and using combinations,
we support translations between
thousands of language pairs.
And with neural
machine translation
announced last year, Google has
been a leader in this field.
You can translate
text, and in case you
do not know what the text
language is, we also provide
the capability to detect the
language of the input text
as part of the
Cloud Translate API.
And I'm sure you're
familiar with it.
Now, with our latest products
that we have launched,
we want to make it easier
for every business to solve
their problems using AI.
Typically, some of
the problems in AI--
AI is hard.
It requires a lot of
machine learning expertise.
It can be complex,
time intensive.
It requires data
science expertise
to do hyperparameter tuning;
machine learning expertise
to evaluate and understand
what precision is, what recall
is; and finally, you'll have
to spend time and effort
to maintain those models,
deploy those models,
and then keep them
updated as you scale.
With Cloud AutoML, we want to
enable citizen data scientists
to customize and build your
own machine learning models
in four simple steps.
And what are the simple steps
are upload your training data,
create your machine learning
model by training it,
and within a matter of
three to four hours,
you can get a working machine
learning model customized
to your company's use case.
And the quality is expected
to be much better than some
of the generic APIs
or generic translation
models or natural language
models that you've seen before.
So how does AutoML
Translate work?
Imagine you have a
custom domain use
case-- you have technical
manuals, or possibly
sports-related use cases
or oil and gas documents
that need to be translated.
You could use Google's
Cloud Translation API,
but if you have high
quality training data,
high quality human
translated language pairs
that you can provide a sample
data into AutoML, what we do
is--
as little as 10 examples
or hundred examples
of translated
language pairs, you
can train an AutoML
Translate model.
And a typical
model training time
is about three to four hours.
So within a matter
of hours, you can
get a translated model
that can work really
well for technical manuals
or any custom use case that
has a lot of jargon, or
industry-specific jargon
that a regular translate API
may not be able to catch.
I can walk you into some
of the example use cases
where domain translation
becomes really important.
I'll use the error message
here as an example.
The device driver is not
working, so the summary of this
is the driver's not working.
Now, if I were to generate a
translation of this string,
or this sentence,
without providing
any context to a
translate API, this
may mean a golf club
driver is not working.
In another context, it may mean
that the driver's on a strike,
and the driver's not working.
And finally, the use case that
we actually want to point--
in another context, and the
context that we actually
want to point our
machine model to,
the device driver, in
a technical context,
the software driver
is not working.
I can point you to two more
examples and more real world
examples where one of our
customers we localized who
is going to come
on stage shortly
to talk about their use cases.
We trained two machine
learning models--
one for restaurant
reviews and the other
was an educational use case.
So we localized, built a
machine translated model,
a custom translate model,
an English to German model
for classifying
restaurant reviews.
And the English to Spanish
model on Blackboard
is corresponding to
educational or legal use cases.
And here is a quick sneak peek
into what the UI looks like.
As you can see, sentence pairs
are uploaded as training data.
A model has been trained.
So this is a GIF that
would keep rolling
so you would be able to see
it if it's too tough to catch
at first shot.
So we provide a
comparison as well.
So these are the uploaded
sentence pairs that
are provided as training data.
The BLEU score, that is
the level of accuracy--
the BiLingual Language
Evaluation Understudy,
which is used to indicate
how good of a model
is the training output.
And once you go to the
Predict step, as you can see,
that's a restaurant review.
"The service was nice and
friendly" is the same,
but "The drink
prices were lifted,"
is "The drink
prices are upscale."
Now "upscale" is a more
nuanced translation
that applies to a
restaurant review.
There's another example that can
be seen in the Predict stage.
"We highly
recommended it" versus
"We can only recommend this."
So these are some of the
nuances that a custom
machine translated model
will be able to catch,
provided enough training data.
Let me walk you through
another example, which
is a Spanish to
English model, and this
has been trained on Blackboard.
Again, as you can see, you are
able to view the BLEU score,
and that's the Predict step.
This was an
educational use case.
So the training data corresponds
to a lot of educational jargon,
and in the predict
stage, as you can
see, graders versus qualifiers.
So the qualifiers-- the custom
model versus the Google machine
learning model, we see
that qualifiers is not
very specific to an
educational use case,
but graders is a
better translation.
With that, I would
like to invite
Welocalize, Olga
and Alex, who's been
one of our alpha customers.
OLGA BEREGOVAYA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Olga Beregovaya.
I manage language
services at Welocalize,
and managing machine
translation at Welocalize
is one of my responsibilities.
And Alex here.
ALEX YANISHEVSKY: And
I'm Alex Yanishevsky.
I'm senior manager of
machine translation
and NLP at Welocalize.
OLGA BEREGOVAYA: OK,
so we'll continue.
And I lost the clicker.
I swear it was just here.
[LAUGHTER]
So we'll continue on the
subject of customization
and how important it
is for our industry.
Maybe a couple of words
about our company.
We're the fourth-largest
global content services
provider in America and
seventh in the world.
You can see some stats
about our company.
And using machine translation
is essential for our industry,
because we're after two things.
We are after
translator efficiency,
and we are after being able
to provide raw machines
translation services,
customized machine translation
services for all customers.
So here are the industries
that we service.
And we trained AutoML
Translate models
for all of these
industries, but we're
going to talk about
examples from just
two of the industries.
So education, as
we said earlier--
look at the examples
that we have.
We have Moderator FAQ converted
from frequently asked questions
by the moderator.
Obviously, that's a much
easier content to consume.
We have created Mashups, which
is our customer proprietary
terminology, and
we have deadlines
for national submissions which
is a corrected mistranslation.
Now, next one would be
translation for OpenTable.
Now this one, we're
not sure if we're
going to be post-editing
it or we're not
going to be post-editing it.
So to make this decision--
basically we don't know yet
are we post-editing are not,
but what we do know is
that we want the most
accurate translation possible.
So what we have here are
regional and national products.
Is it accurate or not?
We actually prefer
supraregional products.
Now the next one, "The service
was very pleasant, nice,
and courteous."
"Extremely pleasant" gives you a
much better sense of sentiment.
And the next one, "We
can only recommend this,
and we will definitely
be back soon,"
compared to "highly
recommend," and again, you
capture much better sentiment.
"Drink prices were
lifted" compared
to "drink prices were upscale."
Again, you have accuracy
of translation here.
And the next two sentences
are just not accurate.
"Happy to return" compared
to "Gladly again."
And "Highly recommend" compared
to "Can only recommend."
Here, again, you are
basically dealing
with an actual mistranslation.
ALEX YANISHEVSKY:
OK, so Olga actually
spoke about very
specific sentences.
What I wanted to
talk about is how
we would actually implement
this more in a programmatic way.
Because often, we
don't have the luxury
of looking at
individual sentences,
and we need to forecast
an entire program.
So the way we do this is one
of the numerous autoscoring
algorithms-- that
we use primarily
for forecasting a program
and forecasting time
to market and discount is
called PE Distance, which stands
for Post-Editing Distance.
And what you see
here on the chart
is three languages for a
client in the IT domain.
And you can see that what you're
going for is the lowest number.
So post-edit distance
means the number
of changes at a character
level to get from the machine
translation output
to what you consider
your human, your gold output.
So the idea is, the
less changes you
have to make as a translator,
the more productive you are,
the faster you are.
The faster you are, the
faster you can translate,
and therefore the faster the
product can get to market.
That's one important thing.
Also, the faster you are and
the more productive you are,
the more of a discount you can
give to a localization service
provider like us, which we in
turn can pass on to the client.
So what you're looking
here for is the lower
the number, the better.
What's really,
really encouraging
here are a couple of things.
Number one, so the
dark red, you can
see that's Google AutoML
translation-- that's the lowest
number, so that's the winner and
the PE distance for the three
languages presented.
And you could see for French,
that that number, compared
to second place, the
difference is 3%.
In the case of
Russian, it's also 3%.
You'll see other example
where it's even more drastic.
So one takeaway is Google
AutoML Translation wins.
What's also curious
is second place
is Google Cloud Translation.
So Google Cloud Translation
is already very good,
and Google AutoML
Translation is even better
and has those lexical
choices that Olga mentioned.
The last thing that
I want to point out
is you have six contenders
here, but you'll
see that for Russian, there
are only four contenders.
That's actually not a mistake.
That's on purpose.
And the reason for that is
two of the contenders, two
of the competitors that
we looked at, simply
didn't even have this language
to score in the first place.
So that's kind of another reason
why we found Google AutoML
Translation to be so powerful--
the rich coverage of languages
that some other competitors
simply don't have at all.
So let's take a look
at another case.
So this is also IT domain for
another Fortune 1000 client.
And so what we
often do is we look
at auto scoring, which is very
cheap and efficient to do,
but we also measure
human evaluation.
So we'll take some
sentences as a sample,
and we'll have a human
being look at them
and adjudicate them based
on a scale of 1 to, 5 with 1
as the worst, 5 as the best.
And the idea here
is we want to see
to what degree this lines
up with the patterns
that we're seeing
from auto scoring.
And here, again, you
see a similar situation.
So what we're looking
for is usability
on a scale from 1 to 5.
Usability means to what
degree are the sentences
understandable and actionable?
And there are two
use cases for this.
One is you might want
to do just raw machine
translation, as Olga was
mentioning with Open Table.
So it's going to come out
with raw machine translation.
That's it.
It's not going to be
post edited at all.
So we need to figure
out how good this
is because no one's
going to touch it.
The other scenario
is post-editing--
so we're going to post edit
this up to a human level.
And again, the better
the initial quality
is, the less we have to post
edit, the more productive
we are, and the more
discounts we can give.
So what we have
here is a table that
shows a hundred sentences
that were evaluated
in these various competitors,
on a scale from 1 to 5--
it's an aggregate score.
And what you'll see across the
board for all of the languages
is that Google
AutoML came in first.
OLGA BEREGOVAYA: Now--
ALEX YANISHEVSKY: Sorry--
so in this case, here,
number one means that it
finished in first place,
meaning it got the most 5s.
So sorry about that.
It was on a scale from 1 to 5,
but these are basically ranked.
Google AutoML
Translation is the best,
and number six here is
actually the worst performer.
Sorry if that was confusing.
So the things that I
want to mention here
is that you see that Google
AutoML Translation came in, was
the best, in all
of the languages.
And you see languages
here that span
romance languages, like
Spanish and French,
which are relatively
easy grammatically;
to kind of mid-tier languages,
more complicated grammatically,
like German and
Russian; and finally,
Asian languages like Korean
and simplified Chinese, which
are particularly
difficult and where
we've seen the greatest
improvements on neural.
And again, the
other thing here is
that Google Cloud Translation,
of the six languages,
it came in number two twice
and number three three times.
So again, we kind of see this
picture of Google Cloud as very
good to start out with,
but when we train it,
Google AutoML Translation
clearly comes out on top.
And this actually
dovetails very well, again,
with post-editing distance
for these six languages.
So here, the gray bar--
again, we're looking for lower
is better because less edits
that you have to do.
So the gray bar, the one
that's lowest for everything,
is again, Google
AutoML Translation.
And you could see, when
you look at second place,
often second place
is green, which
is Google Cloud Translation,
and the other ones
are far, far worse.
And you could see
that the difference
between the gray and the green
is already fairly significant.
So again, we're
seeing this picture
of very, very good quality when
we train AutoML Translation.
And as Sudheera said, we can
basically get these models back
in three, four hours and start
benchmarking and rolling them
out into production immediately.
ALEX YANISHEVSKY:
And maybe I could
say a couple of words
about the edit distance.
As I said earlier, if in
the case of OpenTable,
we don't know if we're
going to be post-editing
or not going to be
post-editing-- in case
of Blackboard, for instance,
we do know for a fact
that we are going
to be post-editing,
and edit distance is our
core decision making factor
when we know how we're going to
be negotiating with our client
and how we're going
to be negotiating
with our translators.
So basically knowing what
we get for edit distance
is the way that we're
basically going to be--
that's the way we're going to
be structuring our business
conversations on both
sides of the equation.
This is why it's the
key metric for us.
ALEX YANISHEVSKY:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SUDHEERA VANGURI:
Thanks, Alex and Olga.
Moving on, I'd like to take
you into a product walk-through
of Cloud Natural Language
API and then dive
deeper into AutoML Natural
Language, one of our newest
product offerings.
Cloud national Language
API that's currently in GA
currently supports four
different features--
entity extraction-- assume you'd
like to extract some key words
or phrases from a text
passage; sentiment analysis,
how positively or negatively
biased a certain article is,
what the sentiment of, say, a
user review; analyze syntax--
say you'd like to get into the
linguistic details or the parts
of speech of a
certain text message--
what's a noun, what's an
adjective, so on and so forth;
and finally,
classifying content.
Our current content
classification API
available within Cloud
Natural Language API
supports 700 different
categories and subcategories,
and this is based on
a predefined taxonomy.
This taxonomy, this
content classification API
is trained on massive
volumes of Google data,
and it's highly suitable
for various categories.
But what we have
had our customers
ask us is to customize these
categories to their own use
cases.
Imagine an oil and gas customer,
or a health care customer,
or certainly again
technical data,
where niche classifications
or labels or categories
are very custom to an
enterprise use case.
User reviews, customer feedback
may need to be classified to,
let's say, the there is a
flight survey experience that
needs to be categorized into
ambience and service or food,
so on and so forth.
So these categories may be
very relevant and specific
to a certain enterprise use
cases, a certain domain,
and there may be
use cases where you
can squeeze more accuracy out of
the content classification API.
So that's one of the primary
factors for us diving deeper
into AutoML Natural Language.
And the first
feature that we have
enabled as part of
AutoML Natural Language
is Custom Content
Classification.
Now how does this work?
Again, similar to AutoML
Translation, customers
can come in to AutoML mail with
some amount of training data.
We require at least
10 examples per label
as a minimum
requirement for running
the model, and about hundred
examples for each label.
That's very little amount
of training data that
needs to be provided to train an
AutoML Natural Language Content
Classification Model.
Now once this
classifier is trained--
and again, this is going to only
take about four to five hours
of training on some amount
of training data, and boom,
you get your custom classifier
that works specifically
on your data.
Your data is not
shared with Google
or with any other
customer model or data.
And the model can start
to scale as needed.
Assume your model
gets very popular,
if you start seeing
huge amount of requests,
the model you can scale to
adopt to your customer demands.
And if you have further
amount of training data,
you can always retrain your
model, and then the custom
classifier scales to
adapt to your needs
your own labels and categories.
So how could you use AutoML NL?
Here's three examples.
You could predict the tags
of a Stack Overflow question.
Say-- this is a very technical
example that the Custom Content
Classifier or regular classifier
APIs may not be able to catch.
You could predict which
news house a certain article
is from.
And health care--
assume doctor's notes,
a patient's notes
need to be analyzed.
Again, 90% of enterprise
data is unstructured,
so given an input of
health care specific terms,
you could provide the
model some training data
to tags symptoms
to certain diseases
and the AutoML Classifier
can start predicting
based on this custom use case.
Behind the scenes,
what do we do?
Again, if you note, throughout
this experience we did not
talk about
hyperparametric tuning,
we did not talk about anything
other than just training
your data, clicking on Train,
looking at evaluation metrics.
If the model's good, great.
Then if the model isn't, you
provide more training data
or tweak the model to
your specific use case
and then you run predictions.
Behind the scenes, we mimic
make a data scientist--
what a data scientist would
do to generate the best
model for your use case.
We kick off multiple pipelines,
multiple Google models,
and we surface the best model
for that specific customer
data set.
It's abstracted
from the customer
which parameters need to be
tuned, which model to be used.
We do all the heavy lifting
behind the scenes, ,
and you see the best model that
gives you the highest precision
recall for your use case.
We've seen a lot of customer
excitement for AutoML.
We've been in alpha
for a while, and we've
had a lot of
customers, one of whom
is going to talk
in a brief while--
Qualtrics.
But we've seen
Meredith specifically
on Natural Language,
Hearst, Singapore Airlines.
There's a lot of customers
within the news segment
and various other domains that
have found significant use
cases within AutoML
Natural Language,
and within Translate
as well-- we
see Welocalize and plenty
of other customers.
With that, I would love to
go into some of the details
that Qualtrics can talk about.
They've used AutoML
Natural Language
for optimizing their
survey responses,
and I'd love for Milind to
explain how they've done that.
MILIND KOPIKARE:
Thanks, Sudheera.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Milind.
I head product for
Qualtrics Surveys--
our surveys, flagship product.
And what I'll do is I'll
talk about the problem
that the survey research
industry is facing,
we talk about the
solution, and then
we look at under the hood, how
we implemented that solution.
We'll also show you
some cool demos.
So with that, what's the
problem you're trying to solve?
So at Qualtrics, every year,
we send out more than 200
million-plus surveys.
We have billions of
survey responses.
And the problem is that--
and this is just across the
survey research industry.
In fact, you would see
better numbers here.
But 85% or more of surveys
are just not completed.
And I'm sure you can
all relate to that.
You know, who loves
taking surveys?
And the reason why
that's the case--
more often than
not, the questions
that people ask in surveys
are just plain wrong.
They are not relevant questions,
they are not worded correctly,
and often that means that
it results in invalid data.
First of all, you'd
be lucky if people
would complete the
survey, and even if they
do, the famous saying, right?
"Garbage in, garbage out."
So if you ask a
wrong question, you
are going to get a wrong answer.
And that's a huge problem.
It's resulting in invalid
data would mean wrong business
decisions, which is
costing the survey research
industry as much as $4
billion in losses every year.
More importantly, wrong
business decisions
means, to quote a phrase,
it's "sinking the ship"
for a lot of businesses.
Now, what's the
solution for this?
Well, the solution
is pretty simple.
Just create better surveys.
Make sure that you ask
the right questions.
If you are designing
a survey, make sure
that the questions you
ask are very relevant.
At Qualtrics, we call it
"predictive questioning,"
and I'll show you
a demo of that.
And if you are a
survey taker, let's
make sure that you are having
an engaging experience.
I think Sudheera mentioned
about post-flight surveys.
Let's make sure that if
you're getting off a flight
and you get a survey, and
if you say that, look,
I am upset, that the
flight was messy,
let's not ask a question
like, on a scale of 1 to 5,
how happy are you?
You clearly are upset.
You'd better ask a more
relevant question to that.
So a quick show of hands.
How many of you, let's
say in the last one year,
had a bad time taking a flight?
So pretty much all of us.
We all have the stories of
having a poor flight experience
some time or the other.
The thing is-- you
probably don't know,
but a lot of flight
companies-- a lot of them are
our customers--
they do take it
seriously, and they do
want to do something about it.
They have armies of
people who are working
on customer service,
working on their end
to fix these problems.
But the problem is--
they are doing all
the right things,
they're trying to get
feedback, but they're not
asking the right questions.
So while they have armies
of people on standby
to fix these issues,
they're not able to find out
what is the issue that you,
as you walk out of the flight,
had with the flight
you just took.
So what I'll do is I'll show
you a quick demo, where we
took a regular flight survey.
It will be very familiar.
You all must have--
from your favorite flight, and
you got off, you got a survey,
and you answered questions.
We will show you
an example of what
happens when we
start introducing
AI, when you start using AutoML
into a Qualtrics flight survey.
So with that, this
is video, and let
me just go ahead and play it.
Oh, hold on.
Sorry.
Hold on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You just got off your
flight, and we ask you a survey
question, how was your flight?
And let's say the
flight was uneventful,
you have nothing special to
talk about-- you just say,
it was OK.
And in this example,
what will happen
is, we know that you do not
have any specific intent,
you do not have
any specific topic
that you want to talk
about, so we will just
end the survey right there.
However, contrast that
with if I say something
like, how was the flight?
If I say-- I'm really
upset, and maybe I'm
upset because they lost my bags.
So I'll say, you lost my bags.
Now in this case, we know
that you're not happy,
and secondly, we also,
thanks to the AutoML APIs
know what specifically
you're not happy about.
So we will, A, acknowledge
that the person is not happy.
This comes from
the ML APIs that we
are able to understand the
sentiment in real time,
but more importantly,
we are also
able to understand what
is that specific topic
that the customer has in mind.
And we ask a more pointed,
a more contextual question
around the specific topic.
In this case, it's
about baggage.
So we ask them a more specific
question around, all right,
tell me more about
the baggage piece.
So as you can see
here, by engaging
with the customer on
a contextual level,
it feels much more human like,
much more conversational,
and that has resulted
in a higher engagement
with customers and surveys, and
therefore a higher completion
rate and a higher data quality.
[END PLAYBACK]
MILIND KOPIKARE: All
right, so with that--
hold on a second.
Just trying to move to
the next slide here.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
MILIND KOPIKARE: I saw the
tab up there, so not sure
how to get there.
Probably want to escape
and you go to tab.
Oh.
There you go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yay.
MILIND KOPIKARE: All right.
You know, we should ask a
survey about this experience.
[LAUGHTER]
Could you go back to this slide?
Yeah.
All right.
Go back a few slides.
So actually, that's
a good segue to--
so this was the experience
that we could enable,
where as you can see, it
was much more engaging.
We were much more to the point.
The questions that we asked
were much more relevant.
And let's take a
look under the hood
on how we made that happen.
So I think Sudheera mentioned
around how the technology
works, what we did was we took
a few of these responses for one
of our customers-- you know,
when people give feedback after
a flight--
and we started labeling them.
We labeled them with a
certain purpose in mind.
So this company did have a team
working on flight cleanliness.
So if somebody said that
the flights were messy
or flights were not
clean, we label it
as a cleanliness issue.
If somebody said
that the flights--
talked about that the
prices were too expensive,
or the flight was
unaffordable and so on,
we labeled that as
a pricing issue,
because there is a team
that our customer has
who works on pricing.
So firstly, we label
a bunch of responses.
After that, we train the model
on those varied responses.
And it did a pretty good job.
It had a pretty high
precision and recall.
And we also tested
that by checking
how good it is in
predicting what
is the issue, what
is the category when
somebody types a response.
So in this case, this is
response that someone said,
you're asking me to pay for even
the smallest things which were
at one point free in a flight.
Well, AutoML did
a pretty good job
of saying, well, this
is a pricing issue.
So in a real survey,
it would mean
that this would get routed
to the pricing department
in the flight company.
And now, once this was
done, we used Qualtrics
to help make a great survey.
So for example, we have
this product Expert Review.
What it does is it will
be able to predict,
if you're creating a survey,
what's the right question you
should be asking, and guides
you on how to ask that question.
So it used the results of AutoML
to guide people, the survey
creator, on what's the
right question to ask.
We also have functionality
to have logic.
So we said, all right, look, if
this customer starts talking--
first of all, if
he's unhappy, then
ask a certain set of questions.
If he's happy, ask a
different set of questions.
If they are talking about,
in this case, service,
then ask questions around how
to you improve your service.
So we made sure that
the logic in the survey
was super contextual.
And the net net
of it was the demo
you just saw, where in
a flight-like survey,
it's a very different experience
than what you would regularly
experience.
It's much more contextual,
a shorter survey,
much more to the point.
Let me wrap it up
with one last example,
and this time I'm hoping
the video comes out right.
So let's play this video.
So this is an example--
before I play the video--
of an e-commerce site.
So we also have a lot
of e-commerce companies.
And you know what
happens with e-commerce?
We've all been there.
We all go to an e-commerce site.
We all go and shop, but we
don't buy just right there.
We browse, we take our time,
you may ask a significant other.
Eventually we go back
and we decide on one
particular product to buy.
And what e-commerce
companies are trying to do
is how can they make
that experience better
for their customers?
So how can they make sure
that the products they show,
the selection, is right?
How can they make sure that
the checkout experience
is very seamless?
So they want to get
feedback, and used
us to get that feedback.
But let's see how,
even there, we
can ask the right
questions when you're
trying to collect feedback.
So for example, if somebody
is saying that, look,
I wasn't able to find the
right selection of products,
let's ask feedback about that.
Let's not ask them
questions which
are totally irrelevant
to what they're
trying to get feedback on.
So in this example--
this is a survey that you
would have with Qualtrics,
and here they ask, how was
your in-store experience?
And it seems like
they're not happy.
And we asked them why
were you not happy?
And they said "The
service was great,
but the checkout was
a poor experience."
So now we use that-- thanks
to the AutoML topics,
we ask a much more
pointed question.
We ask them, all right, tell
me more about checkout--
not service, not
product selection--
we get straight to
the point, ask them
specifically about that issue.
And the survey is shot, it's
sweet, it's to the point.
And net net, it's much
more engaging experience,
and you get the answers which
can help you make decisions.
So that's how we use
AutoML and Qualtrics
to create engaging surveys.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SUDHEERA VANGURI:
Thanks, Milind.
It is confusing.
[LAUGHTER]
And I can imagine why.
So we saw AutoML Natural
Language empowered Qualtrics
to build more
intelligent surveys,
both to ask good
questions as well
as to consolidate the
feedback from those surveys
and analyze those surveys and
get that feedback loop going.
And that creates
a virtuous cycle
of data-driven decision making.
AutoML Natural
Language has also been
helping a lot of customers
in the news domain.
Hearst newspapers, for instance.
Let me tell you a
little example about how
Hearst used AutoML
Natural Language to build
their own custom classifier.
News organizations
typically have
a large repository
of ephemeral content,
as well as evergreen content.
By evergreen content,
I mean articles
that can be resurfaced over
and over again to customers.
These articles have
a longer shelf life,
and they can be fed into
recommendation engines,
they can be used to
personalize and increase
the engagement of
these websites.
So Hearst build a
custom classifier,
and again, ephemeral content
versus evergreen content.
If you were to tag news
articles with these two labels,
any regular classifier
would not have these labels
in the first place for you to go
ahead and build on top of this.
This would require a lot of
manual model building process.
So within a matter
of a couple of days,
or hours in AutoML
NL's case, Hearst
was able to load some
amount of training data,
provide certain articles that
were manually picked and tagged
by their editors as
ephemeral content
versus editorial
evergreen content.
And with that Custom
Classifier Model that they got,
natural language typically
takes about four to five hours,
based on our internal tests.
So after four to five
hours of training,
the Custom Classifier Model was
able to predict, with accuracy
in the high 90s, whether
an article was ephemeral
or whether it was evergreen.
Now Hearst is able to
use that, and they're
ready to deploy this
model into production
to start to build recommendation
engines on top of this model.
They're also trying to optimize
using AutoML NL the foundation
that they've built with the
AutoML NL Custom Classifier
Model to improve
their ad systems.
So that's the power of
AutoML Natural Language.
The simple process of
building a custom classifier
can provide huge cost savings,
automate physical processes,
and enable use cases that
weren't possible before.
To quickly summarize,
if there was
one key takeaway from this
session on both AutoML Natural
Language as well as AutoML
Translate, high accuracy
customization, and easy to
use machine learning models.
These are the key
value propositions
that we would like to summarize
the AutoML NL and the AutoML
Translate products.
If there are any
further questions,
I'm happy to take Q&A
right after this session.
We'll be right outside.
There's also a
couple of T-shirts
I would like to give away.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
There are more resources here--
Cloud Translate, the landing
pages, there's documentation.
There's also some Getting
Started tutorials,
and Quick Starts
available for your use.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]